[Musique]
le masque à l'extérieur c'est fini les
français sont soulagés mais certains
préfèrent encore rester prudent bas les
masques
ouais chouette vous me disiez tout à
l'heure que vous n'étiez pas au courant
que jean castex avait pris la parole
samedi il a annoncé la fin du couvre feu
à partir de dimanche soir
sérieusement c'est l'excellent ça et
c'est une autre bonne nouvelle aussi le
port du masque
il sera plus obligatoire en extérieur à
partir de demain là ce qu'on est en
train de nous vendre actuellement à
travers le grand reset
c'est un changement de monde qui va
conduire à l' esclavage de reset qu'est
ce que c'est ça le grand j'ai pas au
courant du grand 17 rigoler legrand 17
c'est le changement total de société
c'est à dire qu'ils vont faire des
propositions et le coc u19 c'est une
opportunité pour le faire pas de vaccins
plus de téléphones portables c'est la
mesure qui a été prise par la province
de pendjab qui se trouve à l'est du
pakistan les réfractaires au vaccin
pourrait donc voir leur carte sim bloqué
ce qui reviendrait donc à un téléphone
portable est hors d'usagé
une menace de déconnexion pour obliger
la population à se faire piquer c'est
radical mais nécessaire apparemment pour
les autorités une élite mondiale
tenterait d'imposer un grand plan de
domination des peuples et satellite en
france elle aurait un visage et un nom
emmanuel macron je vais envoyer mes yeux
marron pâle et des lycées donc là c'est
parce que c'est un bond de chez lui déjà
vous avez piocher justement dans la
fontaine pour expliquer le présent et
notamment le confinement vous l'avais
dit au président en parlant de la
technocratie en parlant de la raison des
gens qui sont séquestrés qui s'oublie
sens parce qu'il ya une femme qui
s'appelle l'ours et l'amateur de jardin
va la refaire comme non pas du tout et
puis en plus et pourquoi vous voudriez
pas que l'art face à ce qu'on a vu
c'était évidemment la télé en direct
vous est le symptôme de la modernité
non madame a dit
mille deux cents je vais mettre beaucoup
plus généreux que ça dans sa cache cache
vraiment quelque chose madame moi j'ai
peur j'ai peur mais aussi madame nous
sommes vous et moi
la même génération donc je vais
considérer oui que l'on parle tous les
deux en france pour moi ça c'est le
symptôme pitoyable je vais vous le dire
gentiment et gardez-les si vous êtes
courageux de ce qu'est ce que paul
valéry appelle le pitoyable de la
modernité
voyez pas ce que je les dis une fois
alors que moi ça fait des milliers de
fois que je le dis et je vais pas vous
le dire parce qu'en plus c'est gratuit
donc je ne suis jamais gratuitement
d'accord donc je me demande si je suis
content de vous répondre
donc on va peut-être s'arrêter là parce
que j'ai pas aimé votre réflexion bien
1300 200 euros madame merci beaucoup
vous avez demandé un prix vous l'avez
eue je voulais remis en monnaie
constante et on ne roule bien évidemment
à 200 euros madame savez comment on
appelle ça larnack nous lance parfois
quelques remarques un peu agressive mais
pas de violence et nous pouvons
travailler normalement
je suis chez n'ont pas bougé le berger
chez pratt et comfort 2 non j'ai dû
passer sur un autre lynch un peu un
poulpe 1 j'ai plein de bras différents
pour lancer des appels différents donc
c'est parti on rappelle sur un autre
dites moi si vous avez autant de bras
peut-être peut-on leur trouver une autre
utilisation
je pense qu fessio navigation pour
qu'elles s'y s'appelait plusieurs
personnes en même temps
vous êtes responsable d'une équipe de
basket féminin oui c'est ça donc c'est
bien l'équipe féminine au heat
c'est top c'est après ce n'est pas
facile tous les jours ah oui pourquoi
c'est un fessier gérer des filles quand
on est un homme c'est des fois un peu
j'ai rien du tout à la moto la moto il
en france oui puisque sa femme se faire
tasser vraie maman moi tu me sors pas
son intérêt si tu me veux tu me fais pas
une chambre ou quoi des fois j'aimerais
bien trop tôt montrent que quand j'étais
ministre que tout n'est plus que tout
c'est hélas la violence envers les
animaux
pardon est ce qu'on peut rembobinez la
violence envers les animaux
on avait bien entendu ce que marie veut
dire c'est qu'elle soutient la lutte
contre la violence envers les animaux
ford espère des vidéos à plusieurs
centaines de milliers de vues l'aquarium
d'osaka en a quelques-unes à son actif
mais jamais un de leurs pensionnaires
n'a eu autant de succès que ce bébé
phoque la vidéo où il nage pour la
première fois cumule près de 10 millions
de vues tous réseaux sociaux confondus
j'ai tenu un cabinet de curiosités
pendant deux ans et un jour j'ai décidé
d'organiser des ateliers pour promouvoir
la taxidermie taxidermiste
si des armes et forcément ça a notamment
à soria qui vient de se faire un noeud
au cerveau encore les grands thermes le
dictionnaire moi toute cette semaine
j'en ai marre du dictionnaire vais rien
compris et à moi sorti une grosse
définition après cristiano ronaldo avec
ses bouteilles de coca cola vous savez
qu'il les a enlevées ça fait baisser le
le cours de l'action coca cola veille à
pogba regardez c'est devenu une habitude
chez les joueurs paul pogba qui on lève
la bouteille de bière bon ça lui
plaisait pas alors lui garde le cogat
mais un rêve la bière une tendance qui
risque de donner du fil à retordre aux
organisateurs d'événements sportifs en
corse bonne nouvelle il fait chaud aussi
dans le studio vous le voyez cette année
sur cet euro on met des bouteilles de
coca les bouteilles d'heineken on se dit
mais après si si demain ce sera pas une
tranche de jambon c'est la chine dotée
de 7 euros exactement jusqu'où ça peut
aller
je vais prendre c'est marrant vous
descendiez du siège pour voir mieux mais
je sais pas si vous faites pareil en
bagnole c'est pour ça que tu as pas de
permis 7 novembre 2014 fera pas que mais
qu'il ait fait un tatouage avec la date
de son ouïe
mythe collector c'est mon premier vrai
tatouage clichés de camionneurs je suis
un peu ému quand même et en plus ça je
vais te dire j'en ai vu des tatouages
donc je pouvais me poser la question du
genre pourquoi il a fait ça mais la date
du permis de conduire
c'est comme une date d'un mariage de nos
naissances non non non non pas si les
amis de conduire il neigera j'ai galéré
pour la marge et mes 13 ans vous rendez
compte
je m'étonne